Speaker 1: It's great to welcome back to the
program today, Kelly while who's a reporter
at The Daily Beast and also author of Off the
Edge Flat Earthers Conspiracy Culture and Why
People Will Believe Anything. Kelly, great
to have you back on. I appreciate your time.
Speaker 2: Thanks so much for having me again. a
Speaker 1: So when you were last on about a year
ago, we talked a lot about how people
fall into conspiratorial thinking,
how sometimes seemingly benign conspiracy
theories don't sort of stand alone,
and they're often wrapped up with other beliefs
that can be more damaging. We talked a little
bit about how we can get people to maybe revise
some of their thinking. Over the last year, we've
seen Twitter in particular change dramatically in
terms of its enforcement and application of terms
of service under the stewardship of its new owner,
Elon Musk. And that's certainly had impacts. We've
also seen platforms like Facebook and YouTube
slightly change, if not their policies, at least
the way that they implement or police the terms of
service around conspiratorial or non-science based
content. How would you kind of characterize
the big picture, the direction that things
have gone in these areas over the last year?
Speaker 2: It's a good question. I think big
tech broadly has been stepping away from some of
the misinformation fears that really characterize
around the 2020 presidential elections. And, you
know, I want to give them some credit in the past,
but also not too much credit, because around
that election, I think a lot of them were more
cognizant of what they needed to do to combat
misinformation, but they weren't doing the best
job of it. I think some of the best work that they
did to keep the platforms from going totally off
the rails had to do with combating algorithms
that they had that prioritized conspiratorial
content. I'm thinking mostly of YouTube,
which had, you know, recommendations that
put the weirdest stuff at the top of your feed.
And all of that still happens. To their credit,
they have taken action against some of the really
bonkers stuff. It's harder to find Flat Earth
accidentally, for example. Yeah, but now we're
kind of swinging back in that same direction.
You pardon me. Twitter has this new for you
feed. It's a total rip off of the tic tac
for you. Feed it guessing what you want to
see. Often. You know, our worst impulses do
drive what we want to see. We do want to see
the weird stuff, the conspiratorial stuff,
the stuff that you're clicking on at two
in the morning. So I do think we are seeing
maybe a bit laxer rules on how things are
promoted and distributed on social media.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there seems to be sort of like
an air of we're really not going to be able to
stop this and maybe it really shouldn't even
be our responsibility. At the end of the day,
that seems to have I don't know if it started
when Musk took over Twitter and kind of spread
from there, but there seems to be less of a
concern with this, at least among what I'm
hearing publicly from many of the platforms.
Speaker 2: Yeah, absolutely. I think there's
sort of a learned helplessness there, because
I do broadly think that it's true. You know,
social media platforms can't administer away
all the conspiratorial thinking. You know,
that's a very human drive we have. It's not
going to change. If Facebook were to vanish
off the face of the earth tomorrow, nor really
do I think should they be involved in litigating
the minutia of what we share. But there are very
deliberate decisions that some of these social
media leaders are taking. Elon Musk, you look at
who he interacts with, and these are people who
came out of like Gamergate blogs, right? These
are former alt right conspiracy mongers. And so
there's a difference between saying, well,
you know, maybe we'll be a little bit more
libertarian with how we police things. Maybe we'll
let things hang a little bit looser. And Elon Musk
going in like sharing the weirdest stuff that
you'd normally find of fortune and, you know,
saying, huh, interesting. Anyone looking into
that? So, you know, it's they're not completely
helpless and sometimes they portray themselves.
Speaker 1: The anti-vax issue has gotten
interesting over the last year because over time,
the truth about what the vaccines do and don't do
for the latest variants has changed. And this is
being used by some anti-vaxxers, including those
described in a recent vice motherboard piece,
as now wanting revenge, so-called revenge,
because they feel that they've been vindicated.
This has become a tough one because to take
something as simple as does the vaccine prevent
you from getting the virus? When we go back to
that first vaccine and the first variant, the
data was very clear that it did prevent you
from getting and spreading the virus. There were
people then saying, No, it doesn't. Over time, as
the variants have changed and the vaccine has been
updated, it's primarily a tool to prevent you from
dying or ending up in the hospital. But now it is
a different reality about whether it prevents you
from getting the virus. Things have changed in the
real world. The anti-vaxxers have been saying the
same thing for three years. It now more closely
lines up with what they were saying all along.
That's a really difficult situation to handle.
Speaker 2: It's so challenging and I think it gets
at a reason conspiracy theories are so potent. The
reason that we can all fall for them is because
conspiracy theories, you know, there's something
that we activate when we do have uncertainty,
when we don't have all the information, when
something is frightening in front of us. And
conspiracy theories often latch on to a kernel of
truth, or at least to an emotional truth. Right.
And the truth here is that the vaccines, they're
not perfect. You know, they will keep you out of
the hospital. They will make it harder for you to
catch and spread this virus. But like you said,
as the virus mutates, vaccines have been playing
catch up. And while it is absolutely of phenomenal
idea for people to get their vaccines, get their
boosters, it's not going to be the miracle cure
that we were really hoping for. I want to say
like summer of 2020. And so anti-vaxxers, who
to your point, have always been saying that you
can't take the vaccine. It's you know, it's it's
garbage or it's going to hurt you. They've had
to kind of tailor their messaging and say, well,
okay, not everybody drop dead three months after
getting the vaccine. It's not it's not the zombie
apocalypse that we warned about, but it's not
working perfectly. And so they take this new
reality and they retrofit it onto what they
were saying, to say, well, you shouldn't have
taken the vaccines. And I think to that point
about revenge, they certainly some of them,
I think, do kind of yearn for a future where all
their political opponents dropped dead because
they've got their backs.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
As we've seen the media discussions of COVID more
generally reduced, we also seem to see a little
bit less about ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine
and urine injections or nebulizer ing or whatever.
You know, I'm sure you saw that guy. What what
is kind of filling the void right now? I mean,
I see their get they're talking more about Hunter
Biden laptop, even though that's a different sort
of thing. It's not really equivalent to, you know,
ivermectin What what new things over the last
six months are you seeing getting more oxygen?
Speaker 2: Well, I think we're seeing a lot of
a I hate to say it, but like Republican
cope with the 2022 midterms, you know,
a lot of people not accepting that their their
party really didn't sweep the way they expected.
So this is going to be a, you know, relitigation
of 2020 election fraud hoaxes. I'm seeing a good
number of environmental conspiracy theories
percolating right now. We just had the train
derailment in East Palestine. That, of course,
was the result of huge bipartisan lapses in labor
rights and in transportation laws and the way
that these railroads can lobby. But because this
is a frightening situation where it is true, our
politicians don't really have the answers. We've
seen this void where the right can step in and say
that this is a plot against you. Either you know,
that they I don't know that the left is covering
up for this or that. You know, it's deliberate
sabotage of the Midwest of of food supplies that
are really on to that right now. This idea that
Democrats are going to like, you know, nuke Amish
country or something like that. So it's I think
that's really powerful. And that comes, I think,
in side by side with other conspiracy theories
right now that are really hitting back at the idea
that you should be polluting mass. They are really
up in arms right now about the idea of the 15
minute city, the idea that you can walk, you know,
you don't need a car. You can walk to the things
you need, your child's school, the supermarket.
And they're calling that a new world order
plot to suppress people. So we, I think,
are seeing a lot of conspiracy theories that try
and fit a more conservative ideology into the
reality of this moment where we are facing fraught
and frightening environmental realities. So I
think that's going to be a trend going forward.
Speaker 1: The other one recently has been the,
quote, spy balloon. And of course, I mean,
any time you get anywhere even remotely close
to aliens, all sorts of folks come out of
the woodwork. But I don't know if I can say
surprisingly, but somewhat surprisingly, you're
seeing some of that come even from marginally
more serious people. Like are are we sure that
this isn't alien life or whatever the case may
be? It ended up being a topic for Biden's press
secretary, Karine Jean-Pierre, talking about it
a bunch of times. Has anything surprised you
in what we've seen related to the balloons?
Speaker 2: You know, actually, yes. And maybe it
speaks to a quaint idea of conspiracy theories
that we still hold where they're the ones with
the tinfoil hats trying to talk to aliens in
their backyard. When we got this this trending
topic, this idea that there were UFOs that we
were interacting with, I'm like, okay, well, at
least we're going to have some vintage conspiracy
theories. We're going to have some aliens. Weirdly
enough, people didn't latch on so much to the idea
that these were aliens trying to communicate
with us, which it doesn't seem like they were.
It was often hobbyists, balloons are being
shot down, but at the balloons were actually
a distraction from something else. These were
a plot. They were trying to distract you from
the Palestine derailment. They were trying to
distract you from reporting on an a Russian oil
pipeline. So it was really interesting to see the
emergence of something that in the past had been
kind of classic conspiracy fodder. And it wasn't
enough in this moment. It wasn't the red meat,
the conspiracy theories we're looking for.
Speaker 1: That's another interesting trait
of a lot of these conspiracy theories. You know,
last time you and I talked about how it's apparent
evidence in favor of a conspiracy theory can be
just as useful as the absence of evidence, because
the absence of evidence becomes part of the
conspiracy. So it becomes kind of an falsifiable
in the same way an event can be an event you
are being lied to and not told the truth about
or the conspiracy can be. The event is real, but
it's fundamentally a distraction from some other
thing. And it's another aspect of the sort of
un falsifiability of a lot of these things.
Speaker 2: I think that's absolutely right.
You know, one thing that I struggle with as
a journalist, I think a lot of journalists have
this frustration is the idea that you'll see it
on Facebook. People say, why isn't this being
covered? Why is it, Oh, yeah, yeah. And in
some respects I think we do have to take that
seriously. If if people feel like the reality
they're living isn't reflected adequately in the
news, I think that is something that we need to
take into account. But often times are saying, why
isn't this being covered? And you say, what? And
they link to a CNN article, right? Absolutely
blows my mind. But to your point, I think,
you know, this this idea that you can, you
know, touch on the apparent lack of coverage
and say that this is indicative of a cover
up or this is suggestive of another plot,
really does show the the flexibility of
these theories. You know, it allows people to
take their perceive the media that they're taking
in and say that it's part of a broader plot,
that it's part of a broader effort to distract
you or to steer you in a certain direction. And I
think a lot of especially a lot of alternative
media folks have really become quite adept at
taking what the news media is putting out
and saying that it's part of a distraction
effort or it's part of a broader scheme.
Speaker 1: Yeah, even just the coverage itself,
aside from this is the real story or not or
whatever the case may be. If you perceive
or claim there isn't coverage, the lack
of coverage is part of the conspiracy,
and if there's a lot of coverage, then it
must be a concerted effort to talk about
that as opposed to the thing which
really should be discussed. So even
the amount of coverage can be used.
Speaker 2: Absolutely. Again, it's a
real frustration. You know, ironically, right
now today, I am reporting on East Palestine.
And so when I'm talking to says, yeah, we're
getting swamped by grifters on the ground,
We've got Benny Johnsons on the ground who are
running around filming videos. And look, I think,
you know, fundamentally there does need to be
a lot of aid there. I think people are rightly
happy to be getting donations and stuff like
that. But, you know, it's very easy to turn
these things into a circus over the amount of
perceived coverage or lack thereof or people's
imputed agendas when what's really going on is
an environmental crisis with, you know, a pretty
traceable back story as to how it happened.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Even as I receive emails
from people saying it's not getting coverage, I'm
realizing everybody's emailing me about the fact
that it's not getting coverage. It's on CNN,
it's on Fox News, it's in The Washington Post,
New York Times. Alternative Media. The story about
the coverage seems to take on a life of its own.
Speaker 2: It really does. And, you know, I
could speculate a couple of reasons why. One is,
you know, I think regardless of political
orientation, I think we do have an ambient
anxiety about the environment. We know something's
up. And then you see something just as as shocking
as that big gray plume of smoke. And that
really grabs attention. Yeah, I think, you know,
the East Palestine derailment also speaks to
a sort of forgotten class narrative that I
think the right has become very adept at wielding
without actually addressing the underlying issues.
Trump went to Palestine just this week when
we're speaking, and he understands that that
is a predominantly white working color community,
that that does often constitute his base. And even
though some of the solutions that could help the
community, you know, immediate donations now, but
also, you know, longer term investments in social
programs that would help and that are very often
are progressive or liberal programs. It's having
a town like that at the heart of such a striking
incident. It does kind of feed into this idea that
these are people who are being left behind in a
way that conservatives can help, but liberals can.
Speaker 1: That's a really interesting
interpretation as well, which which makes a
lot of sense. The book is now in paperback,
Off the Edge, Flat Earthers, Conspiracy Culture
and Why People Will Believe Anything. We've been
speaking with the book's author, reporter
at The Daily Beast. Kelly, while Kelly,
always appreciate your time and insights.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much for having me.